hey guys Ryan the right here talking to
you guys tonight
about this new trailer that everyone in
the world has told me to watch the
second it was released the Godzilla UK
trailer it has to be different than the
one in America because the American one
is pretty [ __ ] sweet and normally
international trailers don't seem that
much different so the fact that people
are like jacked up about this
international trailer is getting me
jacked up it's getting me so jacked up I
want to jack off okay with Godzilla
already is looking it just it looks
incredible I saw the latest trailer in
the theaters I was like wow this is
terrifying this looks like a genuinely
scary like monster flick and so I'm
excited to see it like him Bryan
Cranston yes so here we go here we go
legendary
they're not fooling anybody that what
happened was a natural oh [ __ ] it was
not an earthquake
it wasn't a type food they're alive I am
NOT crazy it is they're guarding so
carefully I need to be able to prove
that it's real chills all over the right
side of my face right now down to my
nipple
the man is thinking nature is in our
control
how many of you have family and loved
ones can you leave and if you want to
help them know this is your chance
the flare gun it'll kill him ah god it's
that terrified
that was a pretty sweet trailer man this
is the reason trailers are made for
people like me to get excited about whoa
you know everyone's been telling me how
there's like other monsters in this one
I've kind of been wondering about that
like is it gonna pull focus from
Godzilla is Godzilla gonna like fight
these monsters I don't really know what
but the idea of having multiple monsters
in there is just so [ __ ] cool because
that is making Godzilla what it's
supposed to [ __ ] be you know you're
able to stop restart this franchise in
America but take it to a level where you
could have all these other monsters in
it just like how Godzilla used to be you
know like when Godzilla [ __ ] King Kong
and a bunch of other monsters I don't
know it's setting you up for a world not
just Godzilla it's smart I feel like
people in Hollywood know what they're
doing sometimes anyway guys thanks for
checking out me watching the Trey look
why don't you look at this button and it
says subscribe if you haven't subscribed
yet go ahead subscribe cuz we got a lot
of trailers to watch together and please
suggest some more because all these ones
I'm watching are all based off your
suggestions that is mainly what I go off
of rarely do I just go I'm gonna watch
this trailer like I'm just going off of
what everyone's recommending to me so
please suggest the way I am the danger